9 novembre 1989 des milliers d'est
allemands convergent vers le mur de
berlin ils viennent d'entendre à la télé
les autorités annoncé qu il est
maintenant permis de passer le rideau de
fer alors ils sont déterminés en
profiter
un moment que n'oubliera jamais haram
radomski ce journaliste est allemand est
l'un des premiers ce soir là à passer à
l'ouest
le mur normalement on ne pouvait pas
s'en approcher c'était dangereux dit-il
mais ce soir là les choses avaient
changé on n'avait plus peur la peur
avait changé
après avoir été séparés pendant 28 ans
allemands de l'est et de l'ouest se
retrouvent autour du mur et célèbrent
ensemble la fin d'une époque
un moment historique que n'oubliera
jamais non plus heinz schäfer et pour
cause cet office et gardes frontières
étaient aux premières loges il a été le
premier à ouvrir la barrière sans
attendre l'ordre des autorités on
s'était mis d'accord entre officiers
pour le faire mais on ne savait pas
comment allait réagir les soldats dit il
je leur ai ordonné de décharger leurs
armes et de me donner les munitions je
leur ai dit personne ne tire et on a
ouvert la frontière dans les jours qui
suivent il voit jusqu'à 30000 personnes
passaient la frontière quotidiennement
et des milliers d'autres s'attaquer à
coups de pics et de pioches au mur de
berlin symbole de l'oppression
une double muraille de près de quatre
mètres de haut et de 160 km de long avec
des chiens de garde des champs de mines
des miradors et des mitrailleuses
automatiques
le mur de la honte était aussi le mur de
la mort
entre 1961 et 1989 au moins 1300
personnes ont été tuées dont 136 à
berlin seulement en tentant de fuir
l'allemagne communiste la chute du mur
en quelques jours à peine a complètement
chamboulé l'univers de millions
d'allemands de l'est comme haram
radomski
ma vie a pris un virage à 180° dit il
tout à coup on avait la possibilité de
voir le monde de voyager
mais l'ancien garde frontières tire un
bilan beaucoup plus dans cet événement
hfr a été licencié peu de temps après
comme la plupart de ses camarades
un coup dur après avoir fièrement
défendu pendant 40 ans les couleurs de
l'allemagne de l'est
n'a pas été facile de s'adapter de tout
changer du jour au lendemain dit il il
ne suffit pas de retirer l'uniforme pour
tourner la page
jai fr reste fier d'avoir ouvert la
barrière les événements qui ont suivi et
la réunification allemande lui ont
laissé un goût amer
ils ont complètement dépouillé dépôt si
l'allemagne de l'est dit-il toutes les
usines ont été fermées tout le monde s'y
retrouver au chômage il aurait fallu
faire autrement
25 ans plus tard il ne reste plus
beaucoup de traces du mur de berlin et
si le pays est aujourd'hui réunifiée au
niveau politique et économique les deux
allemagnes vivront encore sans doute
bien longtemps dans les mémoires et dans
les coeurs de beaucoup de ses citoyens
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
berlin